most chemists like me
don't think all that much about the
nucleus of the atoms we do chemistry
with we worry about the electrons
because they're involved in the bombs
but the nucleus or the structure of the
nucleus usually we don't think about so
as you know
the nucleus of an atom is made up of
protons that are positively charged and
the number of those protons Define which
element it is
10 for neon 11 for sodium 12 for
magnesium and so on but the number of
neutrons is not fixed in the same way
you can have more neutrons in the
nucleus and it's still the same element
atoms of the same element but with
different numbers of neutrons are called
Isotopes we have a video about deuterium
the isotope of hydrogen that has one
proton and one Neutron hydrogen normally
just has one proton there's nisotope
tritium weight of three which has one
proton and two neutrons and so on the
really interesting question is for a
given element what is the maximum number
of neutrons that could possibly exist
before the nucleus fell apart I've been
helped in this question
by our good friend nange
who has produced the most wonderful
chart it's too big to show the whole
thing
wow
okay yeah these
Gray colored elements are the ones that
we normally see naturally occurring
and the blue ones and the pink ones that
have been made synthetically in some way
and the key question for theoreticians
is how many neutrons you can add which
physicists call the drip line I never
heard of this expression till I read the
paper a few days ago so this is a bit
like there's always these record
attempts for how many people can you fit
in a mini you also have how many
neutrons can you fit in a nucleus yes
but there is no theoretical value in
knowing how many people you can get into
a mini especially as the mini has got
bigger over the years
but
knowing the drip line is really quite
important for the theory of the nucleus
some of you will remember that we had
the video about this very unusual
isotope of calcium called calcium 48
that has 28 neutrons that is
particularly stable and can be used for
synthesizing all sorts of super heavy
elements I was shown a bottle of calcium
48. it was too valuable for them to
allow me to touch it with my shaking
hands but Brady managed to video it now
there's a very recent paper here on the
discovery of sodium 39 sodium 39 would
be 11 protons which defines sodium plus
this magic number of 28 neutrons this
would be the heaviest isotope of sodium
ever made people have managed to make
sodium 37
but the question was is that the drip
line or could you make a heavier one
it's not easy to make these Isotopes a
group in Japan reichen
and a huge group of researchers you can
see all the authors on the paper
have done experiments where they
accelerate calcium 48 ions and Collide
it with the target of beryllium this
time instead of trying to add the atomic
numbers of the elements together they're
trying to smash things up
and look at the atoms that are produced
so over quite a long period of
bombardment of beryllium they managed to
observe nine atoms of sodium 39 this is
really not a huge number of atoms so
they found it kind of like amongst the
debris
they tune their detector so all the
other rubbish that was generated all the
other Isotopes didn't get through to the
detector and so they could detect
sodium 39 this is quite unusual because
previously when we've talked about
accelerating calcium it was the Light
Element bashing into something that was
really heavy now it's reversed Light
Element is the target heavy one is the
projectile obviously with nine atoms
this is not of chemical significance but
it is really exciting because it moves
the drip line from sodium and shows that
the 28 neutrons really does seem to have
some magic number they also found
magnesium 40 magnesium has 12 protons
which will also have the 28 neutrons but
it's not clear whether you could make
even heavier magnesium yet but I think
what is really important about this
is that there is still an awful lot that
we need to learn about the structure of
atoms getting that information requires
really quite complicated equipment
very rare Isotopes to use in the
experiment and a huge team of scientists
and modern science is becoming more and
more collaborative
Garden of the days where a single
scientist can make a wonderful
Discovery you need lots of people
working together to do it do we know
what makes a nucleus stable or not
stable then is it like the geometry of
the way it's packed is it there's you
know I look at that thing on your desk
there and think oh okay is it is it the
way we arrange all that all the
particles or I mean why 28 what's what's
going on here
the answer is
that I don't know why these things are
stable but there are rival theories
which explain the possible stability and
it is observing these
very rare isotopes that tells which
theories are the ones that are likely to
be correct
of course there's an awfully long way to
go to get through the whole periodic
table the drip line is now probably
established to Element 11 or perhaps 12.
but there's still another
many atoms to get to
agonesson element 118.
so that it kind of remains as it is in
there
where do you get all that stuff Neil so
you can imagine water which is H2O